heutigen sendung oder anders gefragt
können wir putin tatsächlich durch unser
verhalten stoppen oder zumindest
beeinflussen unter stellt sich auch die
frage was kommt da jetzt noch alles auf
uns verbraucher innen zu denn momentan
explodieren ja die energie und ölpreise
und ein ende ist noch nicht abzusehen
wir diskutieren dieses thema gerne mit
euch fragen und kommentare wie immer an
uns und mit unseren beiden gästen
nämlich mit annabel oelmann von der
verbraucherzentrale bremen die uns mit
einigen tipps hoffentlich versorgen kann
und davor und jetzt gleich mit frau
professor veronika grimm
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin von der uni
erlangen nürnberg unter anderem auch
mitglied des sachverständigenrats der
bundesregierung guten abend frau
professor grimm
energiesparen gegen putins krieg das
klingt auf den ersten blick vielleicht
ein bisschen naiv aber inwieweit können
wir wenn auch nur indirekt durch unser
verhalten das beeinflussen was in moskau
und damit auch in der ukraine passiert
ja das bleibt abzuwarten das ist
natürlich auch eine frage die
sicherheitspolitisch diskutiert und
entschieden werden muss es stehen ja
lieferstopps zumindest im raum das ist
jetzt unklar ob die eu sich dazu
entschließen wird im moment sieht es
erstmal nicht danach aus aber es kann
natürlich auch umgekehrt zu sein dass
russland sich dazu entscheidet die öl-
gas- lieferungen einzustellen wie viel
das tatsächlich an dem aktuellen
kriegsgeschehen ändert ich bin da eher
skeptisch das ist jetzt dazu beiträgt
tatsächlich diesen konflikt zu
deeskalieren aber man könnte schon
denken dass dadurch eine weitere
eskalation verhindert oder zumindest
eingedämmt werden kann das wäre ja
zumindest schon mal einen teilerfolg
bevor wir weiter sprechen schauen wir
uns nochmal die gegenwärtige situation
insbesondere an den tankstellen an
thomas tonn mit einem überblick
kopfschütteln an der zapfsäule immer
höher schnell die preise für sprit
ebenso für gas und für heizöl
gründe sanktionen gegen moskau und
drohungen aus moskau lieferungen
einzustellen die folgen angst und
spekulationen dass energie aus russland
aus bleibt das heizt die ölpreise
weltweit an ein barrel also 159 liter
kostete lange meist weniger als 100
dollar heute mehr als
122 höhe warder monats
durchschnittspreis nur vor zehn jahren
auch der gaspreis steigt teuer war es
schon vergangenes jahr jetzt erklingt
der preis neue rekordhöhen einen nie
dagewesenen sprung gibt es bei den
spritkosten der liter super e10 oder
steigt im bundesschnitt jetzt die marke
von 2 eur 10 und diesel ist sogar noch
teurer
das liegt übrigens daran dass
deutschland 15 prozent des diesels aus
russland bezieht die preise steigen und
die unruhe bei den verbrauchern
ja in der tat unruhe macht sich breit
ich diesmal ein paar kommentare vor die
uns erreicht haben über youtube no
hinterlegen ich habe mein auto letztes
jahr abgegeben an meine familie der
preis war von 61 war damals schon zu
hoch obwohl es nur knapp drei bis vier
liter verbraucht mit 300 euro was nach
der miete übrig bleibt für lebensmittel
und alles andere wie internet heizung
strom etc fühle ich mich arm und
herzallerliebst schreibt uns über
youtube auswirkungen auf den alltag
weniger im geldbeutel haben gerade
diesel für zwei euro 22 pro liter tanken
müssen einfach nur noch schrecklich was
man uns dazu mutet angesichts dieser
doch stark gestiegenen energiepreise
fragen sich natürlich viele menschen in
deutschland wo soll das alles noch enten
und wie sollen sie das bezahlen wie
schätzen sie die derzeitige lage ein
wir sind natürlich in einer sehr
außergewöhnlichen lage einfach deshalb
weil wir aus der letzten krise quasi
rauskommen dies dann auch nicht ganz
vorbei aber die dreht jetzt sehr stark
in den hintergrund die korona krise und
die energiepreise hatten sich ja schon
sehr dynamisch entwickelt waren schon
gestiegen nach der korona krise wird
einfach die nachfrage zurück gekommen
ist und deswegen auch die nachfrage nach
energie gestiegen ist und energie
einfach teurer wurde da sind die
gaspreise
angestiegen auch bedenklich angestiegen
und man hat immer gedacht das wird sich
dann wieder geben die werden relativ
schnell wieder abfallen aber dadurch
dass wir jetzt diese zwei krisen
untereinander haben wird das
wahrscheinlich nicht passieren das heißt
wir werden noch länger mit diesem hohen
energiepreisen leben müssen und da gibt
es natürlich dann auch nachlaufende
effekte beim benzinpreis an der
tankstelle merkt man das immer sehr
schnell weil dieser preis auch sehr
schnell weitergegeben wird in anderen
bereichen sind oft langfristige verträge
dahinter auch mit den verbrauchern in
der wärmeversorgung zum beispiel und da
werden dann die kosten stück für stück
weiter gegeben und auch in richtung
lebensmittelprodukte wird es
preissteigerungen geben einfach dadurch
dass auch die kostensteigerungen der
hersteller die durch die brunnen
energiepreise jetzt bestehen die werden
eben stück für stück auch in den preisen
weitergereicht an die verbraucher dann
gibt es weitere nachlaufend effekte als
wir werden noch länger in einem umfeld
mit
steigenden preis mit informationen leben
müssen und die politik muss dann
natürlich jetzt vorsorge treffen dass
diejenigen die diese harten nicht tragen
können auf projektes einkommen dass das
abgefedert das ist eine entlastung gibt
einige dinge sind ja bereits seitens der
regierung beschlossen also um die bürger
angesichts der steigenden energiepreise
zu entlassen haben sich die spitzen der
ampel koalition auf konkrete maßnahmen
verständigt beispielsweise soll zum
ersten juli die eeg umlage auf den
strompreis wegfallen außerdem soll es
steuerliche entlastungen geben
rückwirkend soll in der steuerklärung
der grundfreibetrag angehoben werden
ebenso der arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag also
die werbungskosten kann man sagen und
die fern
pendlerpauschale sind diese maßnahmen
aus ihrer sicht frau professor grimm
sind die richtig und sind sie auch schon
ausreichend
er die maßnahmen die jetzt geschlossen
wurden sind richtig die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage das war etwas was lange schon
vorgeschlagen wurde einfach auch um die
energiewende voranzutreiben weil die
energiewende auch die transformation zur
klimaneutralität die schaffen wir indem
wir mehr und mehr den zunehmend
erneuerbaren strom nutzen und darf somit
strom billig sein es war eigentlich
schon immer paradox dass der strom durch
abgaben und umlagen
er war das ist gar nicht attraktiv war
zu elektrifizieren und das ist jetzt
damit geschehen die eeg-umlage ist wird
jetzt abgeschafft dhs findet diese
entlastung stadt gegen das natürlich
jetzt auch zum richtigen zeitpunkt kommt
und gleichzeitig wird der strom billiger
das heißt der anreiz zu elektrifizieren
wird auch größer man hätte auch die
stromsteuer noch abschaffen können das
könnte man vielleicht auch noch anwender
jetzt mehr drückt die
steuererleichterung sind sicherlich auch
zielführend es gibt
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale für
pendler die sehr weit pendeln es gibt ja
auch die heizkostenzuschüsse für
bestimmte personengruppen also da ist
schon ein großes paket auf den weg
gebracht worden jetzt muss man sehen ob
das ausreicht unter umständen wenn die
situation lange anhält gibt es da noch
weiteren bedarf und dann muss man glaube
ich sie hat vier gerichte spruch man
muss diejenigen entlasten mit unteren
und mittleren einkommen die wirklich die
harten nicht tragen können und man muss
sehr aufpassen glaube ich dass man nicht
durch die entlastungen den klimaschutz
konterkarieren weil das ist ja dieser
weg aus der abhängigkeit heraus es wird
ja jetzt auch ganz oft betont in den
kommentaren dass wir eigentlich aus der
abhängigkeit von russland heraus kommen
indem wir die energiewende jetzt auch
schnell noch schneller vorantreiben als
wir das machen wollten und deswegen
müssen natürlich jetzt auch die anreize
fossile energieträger einzusparen und
erneuerbare zu nutzen - natürlich
bestehen ja ich lese gerade noch mal ein
kommentar von watch it for you tube was
in deutschland diesbezüglich abgeht ist
eine bodenlose frechheit diskutiert
nicht zu viel und streicht oder senkt
eine steuer der gewinner ist der start
da ist natürlich überspitzt formuliert
aber dahinter steckt natürlich noch mal
die frage nach der zusammensetzung auch
des benzinpreises sehen sie da
handlungsspielraum dass man da sagt naja
gut okay ist ja auch ein teil eben
steuer und abgaben dass man das
irgendwie nochmal umverteilt
ich glaube man muss jetzt sehr darauf
achten dass man tatsächlich nicht in der
kompletten breite entlastet sondern
diejenigen die tatsächlich ein geringes
einkommen haben und das sind nicht nur
die unteren einkommen das sind auch die
mittleren 1 da sind auch viele leute
viele familien dabei die schon sehr
stark aufs geld gucken müssen und da
muss man jetzt ansetzen generell jetzt
die preise zu kaufen oder zu deckeln das
wäre schwierig weil das ja auch der fall
ist und wir reden ja auch selten der
diskussion die möglichkeit dass es eben
knappheiten auch gibt dass es einen
lieferstopp geben könnte ist unabhängig
davon ob die eu den beschließt oder ob
das von seiten russlands als druckmittel
benutzt wird wir müssen ja auf jeden
fall sehen dass wir jetzt auch anreize
aufrechterhalten energie einzusparen und
in dem umfeld ist es natürlich jetzt
sehr sehr schwierig einfach zu sagen wir
denken preise fossiler energieträger da
müssten wir auf eine andere art
entlasten aber ich denke das ist auf
jeden fall möglich und der staat hat
auch ausreichend spielerin an das zu
machen ja wir gehen gleich nochmal ein
paar maßnahmen durch auch dann im detail
vielleicht vorher noch dieses hier die
deutsche unternehmensinitiative
energieeffizienz zu der rund 200 firmen
gehören fordert von der bundesregierung
eine energiesparkampagne also ein großes
programm programm insgesamt insbesondere
auch was die gebäudesanierung angeht wie
groß sehen sie hier den handlungsbedarf
ja genau das geht genau in die richtige
richtung das ist glaube ich jetzt in der
situation unglaublich wichtig in der
energieeffizienz ist ein sehr breites
feld gibt ganz viele akteure die da
irgendwie involviert werden müssen in
den kommunen das sind die haushalte das
sind unternehmen die einsparpotenziale
haben das ist jeder einzelne in seinem
verhalten und in der energieeffizienz
also in dem einsparen von energie wann
wir in der vergangenheit immer viel viel
schlechter als wir das sein wollten also
die bundesregierung hat da ihre ziele
erreicht und das ist auch dass wegen der
fall weil das sind sehr kleinteilige
feld ist und weil man viele leute
koordinieren muss und auch die
aufmerksamkeit der menschen oftmals
nicht bekommen hat für diese themen und
jetzt mit diesen hohen energiepreisen
ist es natürlich total anders jetzt
würden wir ein optimales umfeld haben um
so eine kampagne an aktionsplan
loszutreten und die menschen werden
wahrscheinlich doch sehr dankbar wenn
man einfache wege aufzeigen würde wie
man energie einsparen kann teilweise ist
das sehr leicht teilweise sind diese
verhaltensänderung aber es sind auch
teilweise
betriebs anpassungen in der
betriebsführung man kann zum beispiel
auch an den einstellungen von
heizungsanlagen etwas machen digital
heizungsanlagen steuern es gibt einige
sehr alte heizkessel die sehr
energieintensiv arbeiten die könnte man
auch spontan austauschen und auf diese
art könnte man relativ schnell durch
effizienzprogramme auch kurzfristig
große potenziale heben das sollte man
unbedingt tun und wenn man das
unterliegt dann noch mit
förderprogrammen dann würde man den
menschen ja auch unter die arme greifen
dann wäre es möglich eben durch die
förderung von unmittelbar möglichen
maßnahmen eben dann auch noch geld
einzusparen bei reinvestitionen auch die
eu kommission sie haben auch schon
angesprochen ist nicht untätig in diesen
tagen präsidentin ursula von der leyen
hat sich im zdf morgenmagazin wie folgt
geäußert
erstens haben wir überall auf der welt
die anderen verlässlichen anbieter von
gas gebeten mehr so genanntes lng gas
flüssiggas zu liefern und das ist in den
letzten sechs wochen deutlich
angestiegen diese lieferungen so dass
wir jetzt zum beispiel sagen können wir
sind unabhängig von russischem gas bis
zum ende dieses winters
zweitens ganz wichtig gemeinsame
speicher anliegen auch über andere
zulieferer weltweit die bereit sind in
diese lücke des russischen gases dann zu
stoßen das dritte ist entscheidend
massive investitionen in erneuerbare
energien
denn diese erneuerbaren energien werden
zu hause bei uns produziert schaffen bei
uns zuhause arbeitsplätze und geben uns
die unabhängigkeit die wir wollen
also fassen was noch mal kurz zusammen
andere gasanbieter wählen neben russland
insgesamt mehr flüssiggas gemeinsame
speicher massive investitionen vor allem
in die erneuerbaren energien würden sie
dem zustimmen
ja wir brauchen relativ relativ großes
maßnahmenpaket das ist in der tat der
fall energieeinsparung haben wir gerade
schon
und der andere pfeiler muss natürlich
sein jetzt ersatz zu beschaffen für
russisches gas und hören wir mal das
extremszenario nehmen dass tatsächlich
das russische gas nicht mehr zu und es
kommt dann könnten wir gar nicht alles
ersetzen in der kurzen frist dann hätten
wir rechtlich eine relativ
herausfordernde situation mit blick auf
den nächsten winter aber das ist ja
speicher war das heißt unsere frühe wir
jetzt gasmengen auch auf den weltmärkten
beschaffen können umso mehr können wir
auch ein speichern über den sommer und
umso mehr haben wir dann ein puffer für
den nächsten winter also auch das sollte
man sehr ambitioniert vorantreiben und
da gibt es natürlich vielfältige
möglichkeiten und man muss da gleich
sehen auch da gibt es sehr
herausfordernde sehr schwierige
konstellation weil ich alle potenziellen
lieferanten von gas sind ja auch staaten
bedienen wir unter umständen wo wir
unter umständen das gras gerne
beschaffen wollen viele dieser staaten
haben auch menschenrechts mit
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu tun und da
gilt es glaube ich einen weg zu finden
damit umzugehen
wir müssen uns so entdecken auf jeden
fall dass wir eben dem risiko immer
ausgesetzt sein können auch längere
frist dass ein lieferant ausfällt wenn
man
diversifiziert und von vielen
verschiedenen bezugsquellen beschafft
dann kann es möglicherweise gelingen
sich eben unabhängiger zu machen dadurch
dass man von keiner einzelnen
bezugsquelle so stark abhängig ist wie
wir jetzt im extremfall von russland und
darauf muss eigentlich jetzt müssen die
bemühungen gerichtet sein und das wird
sehr herausfordernd vor allen dingen mit
blick auf die kurze frist weil natürlich
auch in der kurzen frist auch weltweit
sehr sehr viel gas in langfristigen
verträgen gebunden ist also so viel ist
gar nicht auf dem weltmarkt war gucken
wir doch gerade nochmal auf den
zeithorizont also was ist was diesen
winter angeht der dauert nicht mehr
allzu lange also es wird jetzt bald
wärmer was ist was den nächsten winter
insbesondere angeht wir sind wir da
aufgestellt und wie realistisch ist es
dass wir bis dahin tatsächlich uns
weitestgehend unabhängig machen können
von russland
für diesen winter ist die halteperiode
ja vorbei also ein unmittelbarer
lieferstopp würde schon auch zu großen
schwierigkeiten und verwerfungen führen
einfach deshalb weil das möglicherweise
wir wissen das nicht so genau was kann
sehr große preiseffekte haben wenn
plötzlich die versorgung eingestellt und
die dann ad hoc beschaffen müssen und
dann würden natürlich auch die preise
unter umständen anziehen das heißt es
kann dazu verwerfungen kommen und das
kann auch die versorger in große
schwierigkeiten bringen darauf müssen
wir uns einstellen auch wenn wir uns
darauf einstellen wollen dass es eben
einfach gar nicht in unserer macht steht
sondern möglicherweise auch passieren
kann
aber die gasknappheit die wird erst mit
blick auf den nächsten winter relevant
richtig relevant aber da müssen wir auch
sehen da müssen wir eigentlich jetzt
schon anfang vorzusorgen mit dem
effizienzprogramm über die wir gerade
gesprochen haben mit den ambitionen gas
zu beschaffen auch mit den ambitionen
möglichst schnell beim ausbau
erneuerbaren energien zu sein das wird
gibt da werden wir die erträge noch
nicht ernten können wirklich weil das
zieht sich ja alles sehr lange aber ich
glaube wir müssen uns jetzt schon sehr
gut darauf vorbereiten und wir müssen
jetzt auch schon gas einsparen wo es nur
irgendwie geht um eben möglich siegers
ein zu speichern um dann irgendwie
reserve diesen puffer für den für den
nächsten winter zu haben und das kann
zum beispiel auch bedeuten dass wir im
strommarkt die gasverstromung ersetzen
durch die kohleverstromung im übergang
einfach weil wir dann eben mehr gas
kapazitäten verfügbar haben um die
speichern sind erfüllen kohle könnte da
also so eine art revival erleben er
warnt müller schulter schreiben sie über
facebook hat ist krieg unsere
befindlichkeiten sind echt lächerlich so
lange viele noch mit dicken autos über
benzinpreise jammern nun ja also dass
auch ein standpunkt natürlich klar die
situation in der ukraine und das wollen
wir natürlich auf gar keinen fall
relativieren ist um einiges härter als
bei uns gar keine frage aber ich denke
es ist trotzdem legitim auch über dieses
thema inwieweit es uns betrifft
zumindest mal zu sprechen und zu
diskutieren
auch greenpeace hat einen
forderungskatalog erstellt einige punkte
können wir uns gerne mal zusammen
anschauen ich gehe gerade mal hier auf
deren seite weil das auch eben im
prinzip also zehn vorschläge sind die
dort unterbreitet werden dann müssen wir
nicht alle durchgehen aber vielleicht
mal den ein oder anderen vorausgesetzt
ich finde sie da haben wir sie schon ich
war zu schnell also zum beispiel das
tempolimit da gab es heute schon herbe
kritik von der csu politisch war das ja
auch bei der ampel koalition ein thema
hat sich da nicht durchgesetzt jetzt
haben wir vielleicht eine andere
situation würden sie sagen es lohnt sich
darüber noch mal nachzudenken was würde
das bringen
es gibt sachen über die sich lohnt
nachzudenken es gibt auch viele die
waren ja vorher schon in der diskussion
und sinnvollen das tempolimit gehört
garantiert dazu alle länder um
deutschland herum haben ein tempolimit
nur deutschland nicht da haben den
sonderweg ich glaube den weg sollte man
jetzt gehen das hätte man auch schon
längst machen können dann haben wir hier
die autofreien sonntage das gab es ja
schon mal in den 70er jahren als es da
die ölkrise gab
meinen sie das wäre ein mittel der wahl
also das klingt für mich schon auch nach
also ist jetzt mein eindruck nach
eigentlich mehr oder weniger ultima
ratio oder wie würden sie das sehen ja
ich glaube das muss man differenziert
sehen wir müssen schon sehr genau
analysieren in welcher situation wir
sind und ich glaube schon dass wir uns
extrem gut darauf vorbereiten sollten
dass ein lieferstopp kommen kann weil
wir machen uns ja auch wenn wir uns
nicht gut auf den nächsten winter
vorbereiten und exponieren sozusagen
verletzlich machen dann machen wir im
endeffekt dieser situation auch
wahrscheinlicher und deswegen kann man
natürlich über solche maßnahmen auch
nachdenken allerdings ist das natürlich
auch jetzt eine abwägung die dann die
bundesregierung treffen muss aber es
muss auf jeden fall ein großes
maßnahmenpaket geben dass in vielen
dimensionen uns fit macht dafür sind
lieferstopp aushalten zu können und
autofreie sonntage können was sein was
dazu gehört die lage wenn jetzt an die
verstopft käme die wäre schon sehr
herausfordernd insofern muss man glaube
ich auch dass mainz um das zu ändern und
sich überlegen dass man da auch
extremeren maßnahmen unter umständen
greift nichts ist mehr undenkbar ich
fasse die punkte sieben und acht mal
zusammen güterverkehr auf die schiene
bahnstadt auto also das heißt insgesamt
mehr verkehr weg von der straße statt
dessen auf die schiene ich denke da gibt
es wahrscheinlich auch bei ihnen keinen
widerspruch
ja wenn auch das ist was was man ohnehin
tun sollte aber das ist eben nichts
kurzfristiges da werden nicht von heute
auf morgen hinkommen da müssen wir dann
auch die schiene massiv ausbauen das
kostet zeit das wissen wir
das ist was wir machen müssen ja und
hier vielleicht nochmal punkt 9 absenken
der raumtemperatur um ein oder zwei grad
das ist etwas was jetzt auch wieder
häufig gehört wird und ja da würde mich
auch mal interessieren wie sie die
wirksamkeit dieser maßnahme einschätzen
würden das wäre zumindest leicht
umsetzbar für jeden einzelnen
ja das ist leicht leistungen selbst für
jeden einzelnen aber eben sehr sehr
schwer umsetzbar wenn der staat das
vorschreiben möchte das war schwierig
werden das haben wir auch in der korona
fanchini gemacht wenn jeder einzelne
beitragen soll viele sind super
kooperativ aber viele menschen machen
das dann eben auch nicht ich glaube wenn
wir alle gerade runter drehen wollten
würden dann könnten wir so ungefähr
sechs prozent gas sparen aber die frage
ist eben wie setzt man es um
energieeffizienz
bestrebungen total wichtig ist wichtig
ist wichtiger bestandteil
aber ich glaube man muss schon darüber
hinaus gehen dass man appelle an die
menschen richtet man muss wirklich auch
ein maßnahmenprogramm aufsetzen das dann
auch dazu führt dass bestimmte sachen
umgesetzt werden dass die dinge auch in
die kommunen getragen werden dass auch
die menschen und die akteure das
kommunizieren deren gehör die dann auch
das gehör der menschen der leute finden
da muss man sich ein bisschen überlegen
wie man das auslösen kann vielleicht
noch einen kommentar zum schluss oder 2
stefan hillebrand schreibt uns
pendlerpauschale ist ein witz der bürger
braucht sofort entlastung und nicht erst
einmal im jahr bei der steuererklärung
und dann haben wir vielleicht noch hier
die ansicht von rechtsanwalt über
youtube das sind ob soldo maßnahmen ich
fahre täglich lange strecken auf der
autobahn die wenigsten fahren schneller
als 130 ich glaube das ist eine
einschätzung zum zum geforderten
tempo-limit mehr sogar um die 100 mit
circa 150 bin ich meist dauerhaft auf
der linken spur stadtverkehrs genauso
lange in der
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit also er
sieht offenbar die begründetheit für ein
tempolimit nicht gegeben weil die leute
seiner meinung nach eh schon so langsam
fahren letzte frage noch mal an sie frau
professor was glauben sie wie schnell
wird deutschland jetzt strukturell auf
die diese veränderte weltlage reagieren
und was glauben sie wie nachhaltig wird
das seien die krise als chance so zu
sagen
ja ich glaube das ist zweigeteilt wir
haben auf der einen seite viele
maßnahmen schon geplant im rahmen der
energiewende die wir jetzt massiv
beschleunigen müssen weil ich schon auf
dem richtigen weg waren und wo wir sehen
wir müssen jetzt nur noch viel schneller
werden und zwar noch viel schneller ist
mir das ohnehin mit der neuen regierung
schon geplant hatten das betrifft die
elektrifizierung das betrifft den ausbau
von infrastrukturen das betrifft den
import von wasserstoff und erneuerbaren
energieträgern da werden wir eine
massive beschleunigung sehen und das
betrifft auch die europäische
integration wir müssen vielmehr in der
europäischen union auch dahingehend zu
gucken wie kann der komparative vorteile
in den regionen nutzen und zum beispiel
wasserstoff im lügen
produzieren und dann nach norden
transportieren weil die ersten import
exporteure von wasserstoff sind ja die
die nah dran sind und diese
möglichkeiten müssen wir nutzen aber
eben gleichzeitig weltweiten importe
initiieren andere vorhaben da wird uns
die krise nicht helfen nämlich all die
vorhaben wo wir eigentlich
transformationsphase über gas als
übergangstechnologie geplant haben und
das haben wir gemacht zum beispiel in
der industrie gibt es verschiedene
beispiel in der stahlindustrie da
wollten wir die hochöfen die kokskohle
buch öffnen ersetzen durch direkt
reduktions hochöfen die würden
eigentlich mit grünem wasserstoff
betrieben aber im übergang hätte man gas
verwendet weil der grüne wasserstoff
heute eben noch nicht verfügbar und auch
sehr teuer wäre und das ist jetzt
natürlich erstens eine sehr teure
übergangslösung und zweitens wissen wir
gar nicht ob wir nicht in einem knappen
der ambulanten und gar nicht so viel gas
zur verfügung haben wenn wir uns zum
russland unabhängiger machen wollte und
das sind transformationsphase über die
müssen wir noch mal nachdenken und das
wird sehr herausfordernd werden also es
liegt einiges vor uns das sowieso frau
professor veronika grimm war das für uns
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin von der uni
erlangen nürnberg ganz herzlichen dank
für das gespräch und einen schönen abend
danke
ja und dann wollen wir uns noch mal
explizit die dinge anschauen die wir
versuchen können in unseren alltag zu
integrieren auch dazu werden sie schon
mal gehört hat sich die eu
kommissionspräsident in geäußert
schlussendlich gibt es einen punkt den
möchte ich unbedingt auch nennen nämlich
die tatsache dass wir alle dazu
beitragen können unabhängiger zu werden
von russischem gas überhaupt von den
fossilen brennstoffen indem wir energie
sparen jeder und jeder an seinem platz
kann dieses tun natürlich gibt es auch
sparprogramme die deutlicher weiter
greifen in die wirtschaft hinein und
wenn wir alles das kombinieren also
andere lieferer von gas erneuerbare
energien energiesparen und sinnvoll klug
einsetzen dann können wir sehr viel
schneller unabhängig vom russischen gas
werden
also energie sparen dazu sind wir
bürgerinnen und bürger aufgefordert das
war ja zu friedenszeiten schon immer
eine ganz gute idee und in der jetzigen
situation bekommt es natürlich noch mal
eine ganz andere bedeutung die ihr
sprechen darüber jetzt mit annabel
oelmann leiterin der verbraucherzentrale
bremen guten abend 9
frau will man was erleben sie derzeit in
ihrer zentrale wie besorgt sind die
menschen angesichts dessen was gerade
passiert angesichts der steigenden
energie und ölpreise ja es ist natürlich
wirklich so dass die menschen eigentlich
aus zwei jahre krise kommen viele haben
das einkommen von feuer bei weitem noch
nicht wieder erreicht bei uns sind die
energie spar androhung und beratung dazu
in den letzten jahren deutlich gestiegen
unter corona das heißt viele standen
vorher schon mit dem rücken zur wand
jahresende gingen die energiepreise nach
oben das haben wir alles schon deutlich
gemerkt da war für viele schon
eigentlich die grenze erreicht und mit
dem jetzt natürlich mit der ukraine
krise und mit diesen auswirkungen hat
kein mensch gerechnet und die ängste
sind sehr groß die ängste vor den
energiepreisen die ängste vor der
inflation aber auch wirklich menschen
die kriegserfahrung auch in deutschland
gemacht haben und jetzt angst haben was
erstmal meinem geld auf der bank oder
wie muss ich mich vorbereiten wenn es zu
einem atomaren schlag kommt ja sie haben
es gerade schon so ein bisschen
differenziert aber vielleicht nochmal so
allgemein wie ist die einschätzung
was was die besonders betroffenen angeht
wer ist davon jetzt momentan besonders
betroffen und wer müsste vielleicht doch
besonders unterstützt werden also wir
merken insbesondere dass die
einkommensschwachen das sind die unteren
und mittleren einkommensschichten die im
prinzip mit ihrem geld gerade zurecht
kommen häufig schon mit dem rücken zur
wand stehen und die bräuchten jetzt
aktive und direkte hilfe die ihnen hilft
es nicht wenn steuererleichterungen in
anderthalb jahren mit der
einkommensteuererklärung gibt viele von
den kämpfen jetzt wirklich schon damit
überhaupt die laufenden kosten zu tragen
wir haben immer mehr verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher die wirklich ernste
schwierigkeiten haben und ihre finanzen
nicht mehr unter kontrolle haben
bereits vor beginn des krieges wurde ja
ein einmaliger heizkostenzuschuss für
geringverdiener also wohngeldempfänger
beispielsweise studierende azubis
beschlossen müssten solche maßnahmen
jetzt noch mal angepasst werden müsste
das erhöht werden müsste vielleicht auch
der rahmen erweitert werden für
diejenigen also die personenkreis
sozusagen breiter gefasst werden aus
sicht der verbraucherzentralen auf jeden
fall erstens 135 euro hilft nicht das
müsste deutlich mehr sein wir fordern
500 euro und aus meiner sicht müsste es
auch so sein dass wirklich die
einkommensschwachen haushalte ich ja
auch ganz klar mit berücksichtigt werden
das heißt dass auch die wirklichen
einmalzuschuss kriegen
was konkret raten sie denn den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die zu ihnen
kommen gibt es sowas wie die top fünf
tipps oder sowas zum energiesparen oder
überhaupt zum umgang mit der aktuellen
situation haben sie da so eine art
hitliste oder wie gehen sie davor in
solchen gesprächen ja das wichtigste ist
natürlich erstmal auch ein stück weit zu
beruhigen kein mensch weiß im moment was
wirklich genau passiert auch ich kann
die glaskugel nicht schütteln und kann
sagen was passiert übermorgen oder wie
geht jetzt alles weiter es ist natürlich
einerseits ein bisschen beruhigung aber
dann ich bin auch so ein typ mensch
hilft es irgendetwas konkret zu machen
dafür haben wir die kostenlose
energieberatung in allen
verbraucherzentralen in deutschland die
kann gerne helfen die kann auch mit
konkreten tipps die ja sehr individuell
sind der eine sagt zwei grad weniger im
wohnzimmer stört mich überhaupt nicht
ist kein problem beziehungsweise jetzt
scheint die sonne das heißt ich mache
wenn überhaupt nur noch abends ein
bisschen die heizung an der nächste kann
das aber wiederum kaum ertragen für den
einen ist das auto das wichtigste mittel
um überhaupt zur arbeit zu kommen der
nächste hat die ich kaufte fahrrad
umzusteigen oder den öpnv beispielsweise
zu nutzen und auch da würde ich mir
natürlich wünschen nicht nur die fern
pendlerpauschale sondern dass der öpnv
auch wirklich gestärkt wird
weil sie es auch gerade noch mal
angesprochen haben und wie es für ihn
auch schon hatten mit frau professor
grimm das thema heizen und zu hause ist
das etwas was auch die leute mit denen
sie sprechen auf dass sie positiv
reagieren oder fühlen die sich dann von
ihnen irgendwie veräppelt oder oder
reagieren sie sogar ablehnend darauf
dass sie sagen ich fange ich nicht an zu
frieren jetzt wie ist das ganz
unterschiedliche das ist wirklich für
den einen ist es ein riesen thema auch
wirklich zu zu lernen zu erfahren wie
lüfte ich richtig wie mache ich es
richtig eben nicht aufgibt sondern immer
stoßlüften und was kann ich auch mit
kleinen einstellungen beim einer heizung
beispielsweise verbessern oder auch
direkt am thermostat geht uns ja allen
so ist auch auf der arbeit etwas woran
man immer arbeiten kann das licht immer
ausmachen und andere sachen sind viele
tipps die wir schon von oma oder von
mutter früher gehört haben aber die
natürlich auch in vergessenheit ein
stückweit geraten sind dagegen ist der
energieanbieter wechsel etwas was ja
lange auch ein typischer tipp war im
moment überhaupt nicht mehr ratsam weil
die preise steigen im moment überall und
wir hatten ja auch schon die ersten
pauschal kündigungen wo energieanbieter
ihre verträge nicht mehr eingehalten
haben tja das ist natürlich eine andere
situation die keiner will becketts fragt
uns über youtube bis zu welchem
einkommen kann man denn mit entlastungen
rechnen
pauschale frage aber können sie sagen
für wen sozusagen die momentanen
entlassung wir hatten schon ein paar
personengruppen aufgezählt überhaupt in
frage gekommen also einmal haben wir
wirklich für wohngeldempfänger und für
studenten diesen zuschuss von 135 euro
der natürlich zu gering ist und auch nur
für diese personengruppe gilt dagegen
die fern pendlerpauschale hängt
natürlich von der entfernung ab und die
co2 preis entlastung in dem sinne wird
allen zugute kommen das ist natürlich
etwas was alle einkommensgruppen trifft
und alles weitere wird man jetzt
natürlich noch abwarten müssen ich gehe
auch davon aus dass das maßnahmenpaket
jetzt das erste ist dass wir aber noch
weitere sehen werden was machen sie
persönlich wenn diese fragen darf wie
gehen sie momentan mit der situation um
fahren sie weniger auto oder haben sie
andere maßnahmen diesen vorteil ich
wohne prämie ist das fahrrad sozusagen
der gewinner und selbst zu fuss während
die meisten strecken problemlos machbar
das ist natürlich ein riesenvorteil
dazu kommt dass ich eher wie ein warmes
gemüt habe das heißt für mich heizung
jetzt bei dem sonne scheint schon
indiskutabel ist da kriegt direkten
hitzeschlag ich brauche es auch er
abends eine kuscheldecke oder so etwas
das heißt an der stelle fällt es mir
relativ leicht aber es geht natürlich
viel weiter die fragen werden ja auch
sein wie wird sich die inflation auf
preise auswirken wie wird bestimmte
sachen im sommer kosten wir müssen alle
mehr an den nachhaltigen konsum gehen
dass auch strom teure produkte also die
viel strom in der produktion kosten dass
wir die eher vermeiden hier werden
glaube ich noch viel weitreichendere
maßnahmen erforderlich seien und da
würde ich mir natürlich auch wünschen
dass ist eine aufklärung und
informationskampagne gibt kommen damit
die leute jetzt schon auf sie zu und
fragen genau nach diesen dingen weil das
ist ja in der tat etwas worüber man
jetzt vielleicht auch schon nachdenkt
weil ich meinen klar die die
unmittelbaren auswirkungen sieht man
aber was das alles bedeutet für unser
wirtschaftssystem für die produkte die
sonst so käuflich zu erwerben sind dass
das kann man ja teilweise noch gar nicht
abschätzen das schöne ist wir
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern sind
so unterschiedlich das heißt wir haben
alle schon anfragen und viele sind schon
wirklich zwei jahre weiter viele sind
jetzt gerade in der überlegung muss ich
mich auf etwas vorbereiten sind
hamsterkäufe sinnvoll unsere antwort
ganz klar nein an dieser stelle
überhaupt noch nicht um manche kämpfen
wirklich noch mit der sorge was ist
jetzt in die nachzahlung kommt bei
meinen energiekosten na also es ist
wirklich die menschen stehen an ganz
unterschiedlichen punkten der
überlegungen es gibt auch viele menschen
die schon lange in dem bereich unterwegs
sind den nachhaltiger konsum immer schon
sehr wichtig war die sind natürlich
jetzt schon auch viel weiter in den
überlegungen ja also von hamsterkäufen
raten sie derzeit noch sieht man ja auch
ab und zu dass leute sich jetzt schon
die reserve kanister mit benzin voll
machen in der befürchtung dass es noch
weiter steigen wird im preis aber das
würden sie jetzt nicht empfehlen nein
vor allem die hamsterkäufe beziehen sich
auch häufig nicht nur auf benzin sondern
da geht es dann wirklich darum große
mengen mengen wasser im keller und
konserven aufziehen das hatten wir auch
schon mal anfangen cola da war es nicht
nur das klopapier was heißt begehrt war
gegen weiter darüber hinaus das wirklich
viel eingekauft worden ist und dann ist
häufig ganz schnell das problem wenn es
dann doch nicht so schlimm kommt was wir
erst mal was gutes ist verderben aber im
zweifel die lebensmittel oder werden
dann entsorgt und das natürlich auch
genau kontraproduktiv verstehen noch
einmal der aufruf an unsere community
gerne fragen oder kommentare an uns
zuschicken momentan liegen mir keine vor
aber ich hätte noch eine frage in japan
nach dem super gau in fukushima und der
zeitweise stilllegung aller
kernkraftwerke des landes tag wurde das
energiesparen quasi da zur nationalen
aufgabe erklärt das wurde wie so eine
art volkssport also man hat wirklich
versucht gemeinsam in einer großen
kraftanstrengung energie zu sparen bis
zu 20 prozent haben weil sie sind die
werte runtergegangen halten sie
ähnliches jetzt für deutschland für zum
einen sinnvoll zum anderen auch für
realistisch durchsetzt mal wie schätzen
sie die gesamte menge lage ein also
energiesparen halte ich erst mal per se
immer für sinnvoll 20 prozent echt
ambitioniert ich würde sagen da können
wir von den japanern eine ganze menge
lernen und auch wenn wir ein stück dahin
schaffen ist es ein guter wert und jedes
eingesparte jeder eingesparte energie
ist der preis den wir gespart haben und
ist sinnvoll energiesparen ist aus
meiner sicht die wichtigste maßnahme
dann nehmen wir das als schlusswort mit
von annabel oelmann sie ist die leiterin
der verbraucherzentrale bremen wir
bedanken uns ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch und wünschen ihnen einen
schönen abend dankeschön dankeschön
so vielen dank auch an unser publikum
wie immer für fragen und kommentare das
war der stream bis hierhin noch weiter
geht heute auch nicht morgen abend dann
hoffentlich auf ein neues vielen dank
für ihr interesse und mitmachen einen
schönen abend bis demnächst